I received a suggestion that I do actual
old AP exam problems and I looked on the
internet and lo and behold on the
College Board site if you go to College
Board comm you could actually get I
couldn't find the actual multiple-choice
questions but you can find the free
response questions and so this question
is actually the first free response
question that they have on the calculus
BC that was administered just recently
in 2008 so let's do this problem and
frankly if you understand how to do all
of the free response questions you're
you probably will do fairly well on the
multiple-choice cuz the free response
tend to be a little bit more challenging
especially the last parts of the free
response well anyway let's do this one
so I'll just read it out because I don't
want to write it on it all here but this
is the actual diagram I actually copied
and pasted this from the PDF that vapor
will provide on College Board comm so it
says let R this is R be the region
bounded by the graphs of y equals sine
PI of X let me write that down
so this top graph let me do it in a so
this is going to be this top graph is y
is equal to sine PI X so that's the
graph of y is equal to sine of PI X they
just put that in parenthesis just so we
know that it's sine of PI X and then the
bottom graph is y is equal to X cubed
minus 4x so this one is y is equal to X
cubed minus 4x and how did I know that
this was the bottom one well I knew that
this one was sine of PI X right because
sine looks like this it doesn't look
like that right when you go sine of Pi 0
sine of 0 0 and sine of 2 pi is 0 so we
knew this is sine of PI X well anyway
they want so this this is the region
between these two functions and the Part
A of this and this was kind of the the
softball question just to make sure that
you know how to do definite integrals
and it says find the area of our find
the area of our so how do we do that
you can think you you know that we're
going to do a little definite
integration so let's do that so
we're going to take the definite
integral so let's just say the area the
area is equal to I don't know if that's
I hope this I'm writing thick enough for
you the area is going to be equal to the
definite integral from so what are the X
values we're going to be going from X is
equal to 0 to X is equal to 2 so from 0
to 2 and what's this at any given point
value of x what is kind of going to be
the hot you know when we're taking the
area we're taking a bunch of rectangles
that are of DX width right so if that's
that's not dark enough I don't think you
can see that so if that's one of my
rectangles whoops let's say that's one
of my rectangles right here that I'm
going to be summing up its width is DX
what's its height its height is going to
be this top function minus this bottom
function right so essentially we're
going to take the sum of all of these
rectangles so its height is going to be
let me switch colors arbitrarily the
height is going to be the top function
minus the bottom function so sine of
sine of pi X parentheses here minus the
bottom function so minus X cubed plus 4x
right I just
since I'm subtracting I switched both of
these signs and all of that times the
width of each of these little rectangles
which is an infinitely small DX and
we're going to sum them all up from X is
equal to 0 to X is equal to 2 this
should be fairly straightforward for you
so how do we evaluate this well we
essentially take the antiderivative of
this and then evaluate that at 2 and the
devalue at 0 what's the antiderivative
of sine of PI X well what what functions
derivative is sine of X cosine of X
let's see if I were to take the
derivative of cosine let's say I took
the derivative of cosine PI
this should be reasonably familiar to
you cosine of PI X if I were to take the
derivative of it what do I get
that equals PI you take the derivative
of the inside right by the chain rule so
it's pi times the derivative of the
whole thing the derivative of cosine of
X is minus sine of X or the derivative
of this is going to be x minus sine of
PI X or you could say that equals minus
PI minus PI sine of PI X so the
derivative of cosine of PI X is almost
this it just has that minus PI there
right so let's see if we can rewrite
this so it looks just like the
derivative of cosine PI X and I'll
switch it to magenta see I want to make
sure I have enough space to do this
entire problem so sine
so let's write a minus 1 over PI times a
minus PI right all I did I mean this is
when you evaluate this this equals 1 so
I can do this
times sine of PI X and then that's minus
X to the third plus 4 X and then all of
that times the width DX well now we have
it we know that the antiderivative of
this is cosine PI X right and this is
just a constant term so what's the
antiderivative of this whole thing and
I'll arbitrarily switch colors again the
antiderivative is the antiderivative
this is cosine PI X right so we have
minus 1 over PI cosine PI X remember I
could just carry this over there's just
a constant term on this antiderivative
is this right here
and then these are a little bit more
straightforward so minus the
antiderivative of X to the third is X to
the fourth over 4
X to the fourth over four plus an Tetris
is four x squared over two or less you
could just view that as two x squared
and then we're going to evaluate that at
two and at zero and let's do that so
this is equal to cosine of two pi
and we'll put a minus sign out here so
minus cosine of 2 pi over pi minus
what's 2 to the fourth power let's see 2
to the third is 8 2 to the fourth is 16
16 over 4 is 4 so it's minus 4 2 squared
is 4 times 2 is 8 so plus 8 so that's
this the antiderivative evaluated at 2
and now let's subtract it evaluated at 0
so this will be cosine of so minus
cosine of 0 minus cosine 0 over pi
all right that's that evaluated 0 minus
0 plus 0 so these terms don't contribute
anything when you evaluate them at 0 and
so what do we get what's cosine of 2 pi
cosine of 2 pi is the same thing as
cosine of 0 and it equals 1 what is the
x value of the unit circle at 2 pi or at
0 equal to 1 so this equals minus 1 over
PI minus 4 plus 8 and so this minus
minus those both become pluses cosine of
0 is also 1 so plus 1 over PI and so
these this minus 1 over PI and this plus
1 over PI will cancel out and all we're
left with is minus 4 plus 8 and that is
equal to 4 so that is Part one Part A of
number one on the 2008
see free response questions it actually
took me a whole video just to do that
part in the next video I'll do Part B
and we'll just keep doing this and I'll
try to do a couple of these every day
see you soon